I think it's worth talking a little bit
about Rosetta scientists Matt Taylor's
now-infamous sure sort of what we do
here at the nerdwriter talk about
morality things like that but if you
think you've heard everything you ever
want to hear about this subject I'll
give you a chance to get out now here's
an awesome video of a dog trying to get
a Tater Tot I'll see you some other time
when the Sam pepper thing happened a few
weeks ago I was drawn to look at it from
an anthropological perspective though I
wholeheartedly agreed with the criticism
of pepper it was the form and impact of
the response that fascinated me most in
the wake of shirk gait I just found
myself wanting to know who was right and
why this is an important exercise I
think because it took all of three
internet seconds for arguments about
this to devolve into straw man attacks
and character assassinations soon as is
so often the case in public discourse
everybody loses the people who are
criticizing Taylor's choice of shirts
said essentially that images like these
can serve to dissuade girls who might
otherwise go into stem science
technology engineering and math fields
because images like these perpetuate the
cultural stereotype that stem is a boys
club just not something that girls do or
as Mike over at idea channel said on his
tumblr the shirt was like the coloring
on a poisonous frog it screams stay away
- some may be lots of people
particularly women Mike wrote about this
in response to a tumblr ask that said
simply kill yourself not the most
articulate way to advance your argument
but of course hate is a huge part of
controversies like these not only for
those who speak out against perceived
wrongs but even those who support those
who speak out on the slightly more
articulate side you have commentators
like the Mayor of London Boris Johnson
who said there must be room in our world
for eccentricity even if it offends the
prudes and room for the vague other
worldliness that often goes with genius
and then you have women across social
media who said they weren't in the least
bit offended by Taylor's shirt and after
all it's just a shirt right movies TV
magazines billboards are filled with
exploitive images of female sexuality
help Kim Kardashian probably did more to
damage young girls in
of themselves than the rest combined why
are we crucifying Matt Taylor when
everyone supports something or other
that has some kind of misogynistic
undertone when none of us are blameless
first off we're not crucifying Matt
Taylor we're trying to show how wearing
a shirt like that on a global webcast
might add to a culture of denigration of
women second it doesn't really matter if
some women aren't offended by Taylor's
shirt what matters are facts statistics
like these statistics that show women
earn sixty percent of all graduate
degrees yet comprise less than 25
percent of the STEM fields statistics
that show women are far less likely to
be published in peer-reviewed scientific
journals and just as unlikely to be
cited when they are published maybe this
is because women just don't like science
as much as men and if you're operating
on that assumption there's little I can
tell you save to suggest that maybe your
assumptions are following from cultural
norms so invisible they seem like
insights about gender really the
strongest emotion I'm feeling from the
internet in the wake of shirk aid is
annoyance why do we have to cheapen this
miraculous achievement of science and
humankind with petty bickering about one
man's stupid fashion choices and I think
this gets to the beating heart of the
matter the dirty secret about sexism
racism homophobia prejudice is that it's
pleasurable its pleasurable to assert
your dominance within a hierarchy you
create it's pleasurable in the same way
that winning at a sporting event is
pleasurable the feeling of being a
winner of bettering someone so when we
think about issues like this we have to
keep in mind that what we're talking
about is people's pleasure about taking
it away from them rightly so yet it will
come as no surprise that there is
reluctant to let it go here as in any
other instance of gratification and the
active sense prejudice is easy to
condemn but in the passive sense it's
far more insidious to tell otherwise
kind and good-hearted people that by
doing nothing at all they're
perpetuating bigotry discrimination
intolerance to require them to think but
their actions and inactions may feel
incredibly annoying that's what it is to
take someone's pleasure away pleasure
that so
normalised so baked into our lives its
removal feels a lot like paint I for one
think it's possible to hold two lines of
thought in the mind at once to marvel at
the unbelievable magic of the Rosetta
mission and to lament the real
contribution however small of one man
shirt on a community of women who began
at a loss so the next time you feel
annoyed at feminists or social justice
warriors or Mike from idea channel take
60 seconds to think about whether in
fact you feel annoyed or threatened and
if it's the latter ask yourself what is
it that I'm in danger of losing hey
everybody
as I said at the beginning of the video
this is sort of what we do here we think
about moral issues try to figure out
what side we come out and if we can't do
that we just try to get a better
understanding of what the issue actually
is so thanks for watching make sure to
follow me on Twitter if you haven't
already I'll leave the link in the
description and I will see you next time